[Music]
now come on let's be honest there's
nothing quite like a delicious chicken
sandwich but
it's even better when it's a healthy
quick delicious sandwich full of crunch
so today i'm going to show you how to
make the crunchiest chicken slider
laced with
an incredible korean fermented chilli
sauce in just 10 minutes oscar young man
pan down pan down pan down so come on
we recognize these
these are called flakes and that is
what's going to give this sandwich an
amazing delicious crunch
light rich brioche buns
cucumber lettuce and some fresh limes
chicken breasts
beautiful mayonnaise and this
beauty here take a look at it now it is
the most amazing fermented korean chili
paste it's absolutely delicious a little
bit of fish sauce brings it a bit of a
pickle in there to sit on top to give
that nice acidity to the beautiful
healthy crunchy delicious sandwich
please let's have 10 minutes on the
clock
now
first off
to cook the chicken it's a breast so it
needs to be well lined and there's no
fat in there when we've got a drum or a
thigh there's there's fat
and there's a lot of sort of texture in
there on a breast it needs help okay so
these
are just
beautiful breasts cut in half lightly
season them okay salt
and pepper
and a touch of chili flake on there okay
and the breading for this is going to be
seasoned flour
eggs
and then we're going to use that
beautiful
crunch of those amazing corn flakes
now
give that a little whisk
whisk that up
don't season that in there you season
the eggs in there it turns them gray
okay
so get the pan on get that nice and hot
and let's start off with first putting
the chicken in to the seasoned flour
now lightly seasoned as you saw i've got
a little bit of chili on there as well
okay
and then from there
we shake off
the excess flour and dip them into the
eggs
okay really important if we don't shake
off that excess flour then it sort of it
stays and lingers and so when you cut
through the chicken you've got this
white
uncooked flour which is not very nice
again
literally shake off the excess flour
and then from there
here we go now
for the exciting part
let them sit there
okay
and cover them nicely
okay
like that
now traditionally you'll be using
breadcrumbs brioche crumbs but
cornflakes
it's amazing
so you want to sort of get down and just
scrunch these up
almost to the sort of size of a panko
crumb
okay
now look
i'm going in there with my hands
and cornflakes as you know we all grew
up with them
and they sort of were doused in milk but
to use them as a breading the crispiness
of this is incredible
and in america they dredged their
chicken two or three times to get that
sort of crunch on there but here i'm
just gonna dredge it once and look
sort of
will be broken down
to a nice flake
season okay a touch of salt a little
touch of pepper
and just
a few little chili flakes in there hide
them okay
now
mix that up from there
lift up your chicken
again
use your fingers
from there up
shake off excess eggs in
and then look just cover that up very
quickly
next one
in
and roll it around cover it up
next
in
cover it up
highly
next
in i've got one breast cut into
half so i'm going to use a sort of
one breast
per slider
one breast
per burger
so i've got each breast cut into half
and per burger you only want to put half
a breath in there okay now the pan is
starting to smoke
from there i get your vegetable oil i'm
going to shallow fry these okay make
sure that pan is very dry
not deep fry but shallow fry so about
a centimeter of all in there
let that get up to 10. before you start
frying always get
your paper ready
to
bring out from the fryer and keep
somewhere nice and close
in order to drain
off your breasts now
from there get your chicken
okay push it down inside
make sure they're coated beautifully
that helps to
stop all your mixture
from coming off a lot more let's test it
first
here we go
and they're ready
lay away from you for safety reasons
okay so you don't splash
your hands with that hot fat shake off
any excess
lay away
and look
so beautiful push those
cork flakes on
top again to make sure that you've got
everything evenly coated
shake off your excess
and then we go
now keep that gas up
okay
again
down
shake off any excess and there we go we
want to get these nice and golden brown
now
wash the hands
now for the garnish okay
now get your towel ready
or when we literally take them out and
let them drain
the garnish we're gonna keep it sort of
nice and light
and simple okay
cute
bye mister
cucumber top and towel
we'll do ribbons of this cucumber okay
so
hold that nice and flat on the surface
and just get rid of the skin
i don't mind the skin i just don't want
it in my sandwich so i just go down
along and look that's the bit there
that's what i want these beautiful
ribbons okay
up
up
ribbons okay
and it's almost like paper deli of
cucumber they sit nice
in the sandwich and more importantly
you know it's got this really nice
flavor okay
i don't want the seeds in there
the seeds turn the sandwich watery now
turn these over
color with those
crisps
beautiful
lovely
turn down the gas got the heat in the
pan now
and that's going to be literally sort of
two two and a half minutes each side
now with a cucumber
get that
into a bowl
lightly season them okay a little touch
of fish sauce over there
okay and now i've got some beautiful
chopped peanuts
in
a little bit of coriander
okay
lightly chop that it's a really nice
beautiful garnish
and just let that sit and sort of almost
marinate that's going to give a really
nice lift to the sandwich
inside there we've got a little bit of
lettuce yep your garnish is ready so
when you start to put these burgers
together everything's there and seasoned
okay
after that your spring onions
again
cut on a bias
nice
across the angle and just open them up
if everything's ready by the time your
chicken is cooked
you just have to assemble them
so in we go
and then finally
get your lime
and zest over all that
and then lift it
to
the next level by squeezing that line
over there
time please
so two and a half minutes to go fresh
lime fish sauce delicious you can see
where we're going now for the sauce okay
tomatoes
speed up speed up
mayonnaise and the fermented chili paste
in be generous with it
from there give that a really good mix
up
the flavor is incredible
it's fermented
so it's got that really nice authentic
korean flavor everything you want from
an amazing
beautiful now
look
how crunchy that is i'm telling you
we'll turn the gas off
okay two minutes for each side
turn that over
and they come out now
literally but they're so crispy
look
beautiful that's why the breast is
perfect for this particular slider
oil goes off to the side
now we start
the assembly this is the most exciting
thing about putting a beautiful slider
together tops up there bottoms down here
tops up
bottoms here first off the lettuce
bang place the lettuce a little
dab
of your sauce
beautiful
spring onions spring onions
cucumber
cucumber
crunch
crunch
this is so good
chicken on
60 seconds to go chicken on
sauce on
sauce on
cucumber on
man this is so good it smells incredible
crunch
that sauce is so tasty
dab
dab
30 seconds to go
and then finally
get your lid
on
and that goes there
and then this one goes there
and there we have
two beautiful
incredible crunchy chicken sliders
done in 10 minutes
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intend if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey intent cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck